Hello to our
first installment
of Molecular
Genetics Lecture.
So this first one is
Molecular Genetics 1,
Chromosomal Structure
and DNA Application.
And then we have
two more Molecular
Genetics. I'd like
to introduce myself
here, because this
is probably the
first lecture
you've seen from me.
My name is Dr.
Tony Slingman.
I'm a microbiologist
-immunologist,
so I've been
teaching a lot of
microbiology lectures,
as well as probably
most of your
immunology lectures.
I'm in my current
position. I'm the
director of academic
affairs, I'm also an
associate professor on
the Jonesboro campus,
I'm also the founding
director of the
Masters of Biomedical
Sciences program.
I'm also a MBME item
writer and part of
the people that put
the board examination
together, what's
called a key validator,
and I'm also part
of the individuals
or one of the
faculty advisors
for the first
aid USMLE book.
Looking forward
to teaching you.
Once students finish
this lecture, they
should be able to state
the significance of
genetics in medicine,
should be able to outline
key experiments
that help in our
understanding of
genetics, should be
able to identify
DNA structure and
key aspects of that,
also identify key
aspects of chromosomal
structure and the
organization of chromosomes
and identify the roles
of major proteins
involved in the process
of DNA replication
and very importantly
is to be able to
compare and contrast
the differences between
prokaryotic and eukaryotic
DNA replication.
So let's talk about the
history and significance
of genetics. Of
course it's probably a
central component to
understand many of our
major disease. Every
time we have a we take
a drug there's an
interplay between the drug
and how our genetics
metabolize the drug you
know our genetics
determine the proteins
that we make the proteins
that we make perform
all the functions in
the body and as such
determine how we interact
with our environment
so genetics plays a
very important role in
addition to the fact
that you know many
diseases have a genetic
and have a better
hereditary component to
them so all processes are
influenced by genes and
talk about genes and
and that and some of
this stuff is you know
basic information
that you've had in
undergraduate but it's
important to make sure we
align all this information
correctly and we
have accurate definition
of all these terms
um one of the earlier
uh discover of genetics
understanding the
science of genetics which
is referred to as the
father of genetics is
the monk gregor mendel
his picture is right
there and gregor mendel
is considered the
father genetic because
he was the first person
to demonstrate heredity
and the ability to
pass down traits
through offsprings. He
of course used garden
peas to do that.
Furthermore,
Archibald Gerald in
1902 was the first
person that described
an inborn error of
metabolism, a disease
known as L-captanuria or
black urine disease.
It's a deficiency in
enzyme called **** I
mean genset so it's
basically inability
to metabolize and the
amino acids phenylalanine
and tyrosine resulting
in the accumulation
of a my product
which causes that but
the idea that you can
have a disease simply
caused by a lack of
enzyme was very important
and a milestone in
recognizing the
significance of genetics
A guy by name of
Johansson basically
coined then the
term gene to refer
to as the basic
unit of heredity.
And so you can see
again late 1800s,
early 19th, late
19th century, early
20th century people
start getting a
kind of an understanding
of genetics.
and then we had an
explosion of experiments
and advancements that led
us to the understanding
of genetics as we
know today in 1944 a
group of researchers
Avery McLeod and McCarthy
basically discovered
that genes are
composed of DNA no one knew
what genes are composed
of in fact most people
thought genes are
composed or proteins
make up genes because
proteins are so central
into function they
thought well that's
what it's got to be the
molecule for the
longest time people were
looking to how proteins
are genes but you know
that was not true DNA
is the molecule at least
in living things DNA
is the molecule that
determines heredity
keep in mind that's not
the case for viruses
although they are DNA
viruses and in those
cases these would have
their genes dictated
by DNA but most viruses
are RNA so RNA actually
in viruses or a lot
of viruses will determine
the genes and the
heredity of the viruses
so but viruses are
not living things so that
doesn't apply to them
and then came the work
by James Watson and
Crick in 1953 and they
basically discovered
the structure of DNA
based on the work of
Rosalind Franklin that
you see right here this
is Rosalind Franklin and
the x-ray diffraction
shown on the top
here which looks like
a like an X this is
basically the image that
Watson and Crick analyzed
suggesting in the
what we call now the
double helix so this is
almost like looking
at the double helix on
the top so you'll see
like a right like a
looking in a staircase
that goes in a helical
shape from the top it'll
look like this here's
on the bottom left
is Watson and Crick
looking at a model and
building it of DNA so
and of course now we
know that they were
actually different
confirmations of DNA there's
BDNA which is the most
common the one found
in most living things
and then there's also
ADNA and ZDNA which are
different confirmations
found in under
different conditions for
example ADNA is
typically found in like
bacterial spores under
very high dry conditions.
Rosalind Franklin
kept focusing on
ADNA. I think
that's partly why it
took her time. She
couldn't figure
out the structure
because of that.
And then afterwards
came the discovery of
plasmids and on top
of that restriction
enzymes. So this became
quite a tool. So plasmids
are your DNA molecules
that can transmit
from cell to cell
so again so they can
carry genes so now you
found a way to carry
genes small molecules
that are mobile and then
you found restriction
enzyme which is
basically enzymes that
can cut dna a specific
location so you
found a scissor and a
mechanism to move genes
and that utility became
very important and of
course from then came
nucleic amplification
techniques in the
1980s such as PCR. So
plasmids and restriction
enzymes were discovered
early 70s and then
PCR was pioneered in
1984 if I recall by
Gary Millis, the guy
who discovered it. Of
course you've heard a
lot about PCR recently
with you know this is
the like from COVID
so people now know a
lot about PCR because
of you know the main
COVID test was PCR based
and PCR can test for
multiple things by
fishing out specific
structures and then
more advances in cloning
i came after that the
ability to actually
copy genes and that's
what nucleic acidification
amplification is
it takes a gene and
copies it more and more
and in the early
2000s was the first
discovery of sequencing
of the complete human
genome which was a
milestone it took years
and years to complete
one human genome now
you can do a full genome
in you know half an
hour an hour so things
have changed remarkably
and we are now it's
in the post genomic
era and you know you
can see what's referred
to as personalized
medicine especially
in oncology where the
treatment is defined
by the mutations the
actual patient have and
that's how you gear
the drug towards that
just briefly to discuss
the human genome
as a whole so the
current data shows that
the human genome is
approximately three billion
base pairs you know
but only one to two
percent and that's
an estimate of those
are actually genes or
that code for proteins
protein coding if
you look at the slide
on the right side
here this is kind of a
breakdown of what the
genome could look like
so the exons and
entrons are pretty much
all this is where the
genes are a lot of
eukaryotic genomes have
what's called entrons
and exons but all
the rest here is just
either repeated elements
or it's called lines
and signs for long
inter dispersed elements
or short and dispersed
elements lines
and signs and really
most people don't know
what the function of
these are and there's
also it's called
satellite allow repetitive
dna and a big chunk
of the signs or lines
are remnants of
retroviral dna that was
embedded in our genome
and just stayed there
again like i said no
one know what they
function are there's
some some evidence
suggests that maybe they
could play some role
in regulation like
basically positive sense
of RNA can regulate
transcription here
also shows another
breakdown if you're more
interested again I won't
ask you to memorize
this but obviously
like this is total
human genome and how
much of it is actual
sequence and then what
you know how much of it
is the kind of inner
space in between and
what that is and so
on. This gives you kind
of an idea of how much
we carry. Eukaryotic
DNA tend to be like
this, where there's
a lot of sequences
but you know very few
genes. On the other
hand through chaotic and
viral DNA genomes
tend to be way more
packed with genes because
they have a smaller
genome and they
they really need
it to make a
lot of proteins.
Now we're going
to discuss the
actual structure
of nucleic acids.
This is a lot
of biochemistry.
now so it should
mirror some of
the biochemistry
you already had
all nucleic acids
are made out of
phosphate groups
as you can see here
sugars and the sugar
can either be the
oxyribose and that's
the sugar in dna or
ribose and that's
the sugar in rna and
then you have five
nucleic acid bases
You can have a
combination of those,
adenine, thymine,
guanine, cytosine,
and uracil.
The two ring nitrogenous
bases are referred
to as purines, and the
single ring nitrogenous
bases are referred
to as pyrimidines.
So adenine and guanine
are purines, thymine,
uracil, and cytosine
are pyrimidines.
One thing also
to note here that
is very important
is the number of
carbons on the
sugars, typically,
especially in the
nucleotide molecule,
which we'll discuss
in the next slide.
But basically, the
first carbon on the
molecule is referred to
as the one prime, the
second carbon, the
two prime, the third
carbon, three prime,
four prime, and five
prime. And this
designation is important in
determining how DNA and
RNA, or nucleic acids,
are replicated, which
we will discuss.
Continuing with
this subject,
nucleic acids, both
DNA and RNA, are
made up of nucleotides.
A definition
of a nucleotide, it
must have a sugar,
okay, just like
here it's adenine,
a, sorry, sugar
ribose, a nitrogenous
base, adenine, and at
least one phosphate
group. They can
have up to three
phosphate groups.
If they have one
phosphate group,
that's a monophosphate,
two phosphate groups,
diphosphate, and
three phosphate
groups, triphosphate.
When the nitrogenous
base, such as
adenine, is attached
to sugar, it's
usually referred
to as a nucleoside.
So adenine and ribose are
actually referred
to as adenosine.
If you put guanine with
ribose, that's guanosine.
If you put thymine
with ribose, or
deoxyribose, it
becomes thymidine.
If you put cytosine
with the oxygen,
ribose becomes
cytidine, and uracil
with the sugar
becomes uridine.
And so that's the
nucleoside. The
nucleoside contains
no phosphate.
Once you add
the phosphate
group, it becomes
a nucleotide.
DNA and RNA are made
out of chains of
nucleotides, so you
must have phosphate
groups. And a
lot of the second
phosphate group and
the third phosphate,
the bonds that
exist between those
are referred to as
high energy bonds.
This is the molecule
known as adenosine
triphosphate, which
you know as ATP.
And of course, ATP,
adenosine triphosphate,
and this one has the
ribose sugar. If it
has the deoxyribose
sugar, it becomes
DATP. okay sorry my
handwriting is not the
best here but so this
is the deoxy version
deoxy adenosine
triphosphate so so for DNA
all the bases are
deoxy so you have ATP,
DGTP,
DCTP, and for thymidine,
you don't have
to put DTTP because
thymidine only
pairs with the
deoxyribose, so sufficient
to say TTP because
we already know
that that's the only
one that pairs with
so these are
nucleotides that make up
DNA now the ones
that make up RNA are
UTP so remember the
sugar there is ribose
GTP so you don't have
the D you don't have
the deoxy part GTP ATP
and sorry I'm trying
to draw with the mouse
it's not the easiest
thing and then CTP,
cytotine triphosphate.
These make up the
molecule of RNA.
I'd just like to take
a second here with
this slide to let you
know that throughout
my lectures I'll
be putting some
practice questions for
you but I want to make
sure we set some
guidelines in regard
what those questions
are for and what is
their purpose. So
they're basically only
for practice and for
learning and learning
of course is the
primary thing and
this is why you are
here in medical school
I want to know that
these questions are
typically first order
so they're not like
second order or third
order just like you'd
expect on exams they're
not board style at
least the majority of
them there might be one
or so but we will do
more board style for
example exam questions
in peer instruction.
And so here these are
just for you to keep
tabs like as you're
studying a slide or a
certain section. Maybe
a couple of questions
just to help you see if
you've got one there.
Please remember that
the answers for the
questions are in the
material itself and
finding the answers
is a big part of the
learning process. So I
will not be disclosing
or giving you the
answer to these
questions because I do
not want to interrupt
the learning process
and this is exactly
what these questions
are for so please help
me in making sure
that takes place thank
you and i hope you
benefit from those try
to apply what we
learned in the previous
slide here this slide
i just took out of the
internet which of
course as we all know
the internet everything
is accurate right
no so obviously this
slide has a lot of
mistakes so let's see
if we can figure this
out together based on
what we just learned
So for one, these
are labeled as
the nucleotides
of DNA, right?
Well, as we just
talked about in the
previous slide, the
nucleotides must
have a phosphate
group. And as you
can see, that would
be right here.
I mean, there's
nothing here. So
these are not
nucleotides. All I see
is a nitrogenous
base and a sugar.
So in this case, these
are actually nucleosides,
right?
Remember when
the sugar and the
base are together, it's a
nucleoside. So this
is first error.
These are not
nucleotides.
Okay,
let's erase some of this.
The next thing, let's
see if this is labeled
correctly. So these
are purines, right?
and so the pureings
are the ones that
have the nitrogenous
base that has two ring
structure and that
is correct so both
of these are two ring
structure so we got
this correct already
let's erase that and
these are the
pyrimidines right and the
pyrimidines have
single rings and these
have single rings so
this is also correct
good so far so good
now let's look at the
terminology so here
we have the guanosine
sorry the guanine
base attached to the
sugar and that's
guanosine that's correct
here we have the
adenine base attached to
the sugar and that should
be adenosine now what
do they label it as
adenine so adenine
would only be the base
not with the sugar this
should be I didn't
see so that's another
mistake let's see if
they got them right here
no actually got them
all incorrect this is
thymidine because it's
thymine plus the sugar
and this should be
cytidine because it's
cytosine plus the sugar
so see how many errors
we've identified so
far okay one more thing
to look at here is which
sugar is this ribose
or deoxyribose so
if you remember this
carbon here is the one
prime right and this
one here is the two prime
okay the angle right
there this is the three
prime okay that four
prime and that carbon
right here is the
five prime okay so the
way you know ribose from
deoxyribose is here
for ribose you would
have an OH group okay
for deoxyribose which
is deoxy right so the
actual term for deoxy
the correct wording
is 2 prime deoxyribose
okay what does that mean
is we don't have that
oxygen molecule on
them on the two prime
group see how there's
instead of OH just H so
this is the axioribols
or two prime axioribols
that's the actual term
for it and so these
are correct these are
the this is the sugar
you expect to find
in the alien if this
was irony we expect
to find the OH that we
expect ribols not the
axioribols so they got a
few things right lots
of things wrong but
you're able now to tell
based on this okay so
this figure shows us
the structure of DNA
in a flat way remember
DNA is double helical
so it should be twisted
but for supposedly
it's flattened here
but let's even figure
out what's going on
here now this looks like
a complex structure but
the truth to be told
by identifying some
key elements that you
already learned you'll
be able to discover
what this is and what's
going on here so for
one we already know
that so the DNA the
strands of DNA which is
right here is made up
of the sugar phosphate
backbone so when
people talk about the
sugar phosphate backbone
they're referring
to this alternating
phosphate sugar phosphate
sugar phosphate sugar
phosphate sugar this
is how the backbone of
DNA is made out of
sugar and phosphate
attached it's got it so
if you want to draw it
for simplicity you can
put a p for phosphate
s for sugar then bond
it to a p and then s
for sugar okay then p
and you get it right
okay and these are of
course all covalent
bonds now attached to
sugar is the base so
right here will be a bond
and this is typically
referred to as the n
-glycosidic bond this
terminology is
important when we try to
study DNA repair, which
is the next lecture.
So here would be the
base. So let's see which
base. Let's see if we
can figure out which
base is this one right
here. And so if you
could see like this
base and this base, they
base pair, right? So
DNA is double stranded.
Here is one strand
and here is the other.
Okay.
Right here.
I'm going to erase that
again so it's not as
crowded okay and then
the bases are making
hydrogen bonds with each
other so if you look
at the hydrogen bonding
between this base
okay and that base
right so this base is a
pyrimidine right two
rings I'm putting dots
in the ring and this
is a purine sorry this
is a purine and this
is a pyrimidane I
apologize two rings is
a purine one ring is a
pyrimidane and between
them as you can see
there are now highlight
them right here two
hydrogen bonds see the
hydrogen bonds they
usually show them as
dotted so whenever you
have two nitrogenous
bases pairing in two
hydrogen bonds that's
an that's an A and T
interaction I mean
adenine and thymine and
because adenine is the
purine now we know this
is adenine and this
is thymine okay so we
draw this here here's
adenine attached to the
sugar remember this
one here this bond was
referred to as the n
-glycosidic bond bond
between the sugar and
the now let's make sure
that we have the right
ribose sorry right
sugar and we do this
is the oxyribose so
that is correct okay
let's look at this one
here the next uh
interaction here notice we
have one two and three
i'm highlighting the
hydrogen bonds so
here we have three
hydrogen bonds and
typically the three
hydrogen bonds occurs
between G and C and
guanine is the purine
and cytosine is
the permidane so
this is guanine and
this is cytosine
yeah and then you can
do the same identify
the hydrogen bonds
like here there's a
couple then you can
figure out and here
there is three and now
that you do that yourself
so you can figure
out which ones which
again i'm not asking
you to memorize this now
you need to know that
adenine and guanine
sorry guanine and
cytosine have three
hydrogen bonds and adenine
and thymine have two
hydrogen bonds but
you don't need to
identify it this way but
it just helps you
understand it better okay
that's one thing that's
important to note
let's say this is
guanine and this
is thymine so this
is here one strand
of dna of course dna
is double stranded
so if you want
to put another
strand sorry let's
make this accurate
because there is
because these are
hydrogen bonds one
half to the auto right
what am i drawing
here two hydrogen
bonds between
an A and a T and
three hydrogen
bonds between a G
and of course attached
to these here would
be the sugar right
notice I'm drawing
now the second strand
sugar sugar sugar
of course the sugar
is not just floating
like that they're
attached with the
phosphate group right
so I have to draw the
phosphate group or
the sugar phosphate
backbone right here
we go see So this is,
that's one strand and
that's another and
they're both attached
by hydrogen bonds.
When I erase this and
get it out of the way,
now you get the drift
of how this works.
And again this has
implications to DNA
structure and DNA
replication of course,
the location of all the
stuff and repair and
you know how does
that relate to cancer
and all that good stuff
okay one more thing
to note here that's
important is the sugar
phosphate backbone has
an orientation in DNA
so first if you just
look at quickly here
you see how the oxygen
here see that in the
sugar and the oxygen
here see this like if
you compare this looks
like it's on the top
and this looks like
on the bottom you see
that these strands seem
flipped and they are
the strands are actually
anti parallel to
each other so how do
we refer to the strands
well if you look at
the strand here the
carbon that's poking out
here and the farthest
out that is the five
prime carbon right
if you count them
and the one at the
end here this is the
three prime carbon
so this is where that
nomenclature becomes.
This strand is
the five prime to
three prime strand
because here is the
five prime carbon,
here is the three prime
OH group. Now look
at this one here,
here is the what I'm
seeing here right off
beginning is the three
prime OH group and
what I see right here
is the five prime carbon
so this stand is the
3 prime to 5 prime
and this is the 5 prime
to 3 prime so that's
how you identify the
strands of DNA which
one is which by the
orientation of the carbons
the 5 prime carbon
and the 3 prime of
each group and again
this is the 5 prime 3
prime and this is the
3 prime to 5 prime when
building DNA you always
have to build it in
the opposite direction
in other words on
the five prime to three
prime you can only
build the three prime
to five prime and on
the three prime to
five prime you can only
build the five prime to
three prime they always
are empty like that
and structured DNA
does not work any other
way but the interesting
part is is that DNA
replication can only
occur in the five
prime to three prime
direction and the reason
for that is the you
have to have that three
prime OH group available
to attach a new
phosphate here and so
we'll have to explore
how does that work how
do you synthesize two
strands if they both
have to be done in the
five prime to three
prime direction when
they are opposite and
we'll discuss that
next in DNA replication
we can shift gears
and talk about how DNA
is packaged inside the
cell so DNA is a pretty
large molecule and
from what you can see
from this cell right
here so this is a this
is e coli here's a
cell it's a rod shaped
and here's all the dna
coming out of the cell
you could tell right
off the bat that the
amount of dna is way
bigger than the actual
cell so you have to
package this very densely
inside the cell while
allowing for other
structures to happen
in prokaryotic cells
such as this one the
dna is supercoiled and
that's a distinctive
feature for prokaryotes.
Now in our cells,
which are eukaryotes,
instead of supercoiling
that takes place,
and that's because
again prokaryotic cells
have circular DNA, and
so you kind of twist
it like a knot, but in
our cells the DNA is
packaged into structures
called chromatin,
and it's a very unique
type of structure.
Chromatin is made out
of the structures called
nucleosomes, and
nucleosomes are pretty
much DNA wrapped
around proteins called
histones where you'll
take a look at that and
so here is the let's
erase this now we're not
looking at it anymore
and so here's the
histone proteins there
is typically several
histone proteins which
the DNA double helix
wraps around the histones
are typically filled
with lysine residues
which are positively
charged and that makes
sense because the
sugar phosphate backbone
of the DNA is negatively
charged that charge
difference creates
attraction allowing
the DNA to wrap around
the histones so typically
double helix wraps
two turns as you can
see here so here was
one turn and two turn
of this core histone
molecule which is called
this is now called a
nucleosome and so if
you look at basically
eventually end up
there's your double helix
and here's the size
for reference and then
you start packaging
them two turns two turns
two turns on these it's
kind of like toilet
paper if you think of
it that way you know
you're packaging the
DNA which is the actual
paper around the
cardboard in the center
which is the toilet
paper and as you do that
of course the size gets
larger and then you
condense these nucleosomes
together and this
right here is chromatin
the structure right
here is chromatin okay
and that's what you
typically find inside
the eukaryotic cell
nuclei chromatin i will
take a look at that
a little bit now
when cells wants to
divide they will go
further and start even
condensing chromatin
more and more to
eventually end up with
chromosomes. Chromosomes
are highly condensed
and that's necessary
so you can separate
the DNA correctly.
Now here we're taking
a look at this is
a plasma cell which
makes antibodies
but that's a great
example of a cell to
look at so all these
dense spots right
here and here are
basically chromatin.
Now just taking a quick
look at here you can
see there's two different
kinds of chromatin
there's a there's one
that's dense which
is right here all this
dark you know stuff
and then there's this
extremely dark highly
dense chromatin so this
dense chromatin is
called heterochromatin
there's the term
right here while the
still dense but not
as dense is called
euchromatin which you
can see right here okay
and so this is all
chromatin so chromatin
is divided into
heterochromatin extremely
dense and eochromatin
dense we don't want
to call it dense and
less dense because
it is also dense even
eochromatin is dense
it's just a different
degree of density
what is the difference
of what's going on
between the two so
typically what happens
is the heterochromatin
or the dna in
heterochromatin is usually
silent meaning it's not
transcribed no gene
transcription is taking
place while in the
u-chromatin there is
transcription of
these genes are taking
place and you know you
make mRNA and eventually
you can make proteins
and this will change
depending on the cell
in other words this
spot here let's say
of heterochromatin
can become u-chromatin
and then this other
part if it's not
needed depending on the
physiological condition
it can go back and
become hetero so it's
obviously dynamic the
ratio of heterochromatin
to chromatin Let's
discuss both DNA and
chromatin modifications.
One of the things
that takes place
in DNA is what's
referred to as DNA
methylation. This
occurs in different
spots and for
different purposes.
And we'll talk about
each and we'll explore
that more in coming
lectures. But one of
the key spots where
methylation takes place,
which is basically
adding a methyl group,
is at GATC location.
So, whenever there's
a GHC, you end up
methylating the adenine.
And so, you can see
this methylation here.
And there's a purpose for
this particular
methylation.
And it's mainly needed
to alert the cell
which DNA, especially
during replication,
is the mother strand
and which DNA is the
new strand. and the
purpose of that is when
you make the new strand
and if there's any
mistakes so that's
your you want to know
which one is your
original copy and which
one is the new copy
because if there's any
mistakes a new copy
you want to fix them
and so that's what
the methylation of the
GATC is for it's
basically for mismatch
repair we will discuss
mismatch repair as a
system in the next
lecture molecular genetics
2 and another again
unrelated subject
is but it also is
DNA methylation is
methylation in locations
called CPG islands it's
a location where
there's a lot of like
citadine and guanidine
residues and the
purpose of those is
completely different from
the GATC and And that
is to silence DNA.
So if there's a
gene that has a CP
sequence on it and
there's a methyl
group there, that
gene cannot be
transcribed and
cannot express itself.
Sometimes you'll see
an application of
this genetic diseases
that skip a generation.
And that's typically
because maybe in
that gen, the next,
let's say first
generation has disease,
second generation has
the gene, but it's
been silenced. and
because it's silenced
they don't express it
and then they give
it their sons and
daughters and then
those now it may be
unsilenced so to speak
and so methylation can
have a big impact on
on gene expression
also histones get
methylated and acetylated
okay and that's an
important topic and
that also can allow
different parts of
the chromatin to be
either transcribed or
or turned off and so
methylation actually
causes you know
methylation of histones
cause the histone to
become more into the
heterochromatin and
more silenced so it
represses transcription
but it does that
reversibly, it's
not permanent and
while acetylation
actually allows the
DNA to relax and
giving it more access
to be transcribed. So
methylation of histones
represses transcription
and acetylation of
histones allows for
transcription and so
there's a commonality
here in methylation
you can see here if you
methylate the cpg
islands they get silenced
if you methylate the
histones the proteins
here we're talking
right not not the dna
even methylate the
protein can also turn off
transcription and don't
confuse methylation
of dna with histone
methylation again this
is the protein that
dna wraps around let's
discuss the process
of actual replication
of dna this is making
a copy okay now um
renal replication is
referred to as semi
-conservative and the
reason that's called that
way is because half
the DNA is from the
parent parental strand
and the other half
is known so that's semi
-conferred to a semi
-conservative as I walk
through this process
with you just be
remember that there's
notes in the PowerPoint
slide that has a
step by step of this
process it's also be
good if you can go on
the web and find some
animation of this
process gonna help you
visualize it because
sometimes it's hard to
learn this stuff
without having a very
good animated visual
so i recommend that
anyway all replication
has to have an a start
and typically the
start is a sequence a
specific sequence of
dna called the origin
or ori site in prokaryotes
there's usually
one origin replication
because prokaryotes
typically have one
chromosome, which is
circular, and while in
our DNA, mammalian DNA,
usually there's multiple
origin sites, like
in humans there's
around 50,000 sites of
origination, and of
course you have to have
a termination site,
which is called the ter
site, ter for termination,
or for origin.
the first thing that
happens there's again
many enzymes are involved
this so we're going
to try to simplify
this process but please
be aware that there's
more to it than what
we have here but at
least this is the basic
that is needed and so
basically you've got
the first thing that
happens an enzyme called
DNA helicase and the
terms and the names
of the enzyme usually
tell us what they do so
helicase it basically
breaks the hydrogen
bond between the bases
and unwinds the helix
okay to open up so you
can actually copy it
right and now if you
if helicase does that
and nothing happens
afterwards the DNA actually
will rewind back
because remember the
DNA in its natural
state has the hydrogen
bonds so you have to be
able to keep that fork
open and in order to do
that you need proteins
that come and bind to
the single-stranded
DNA and actually keep
it open and those
are called single
-stranded binding proteins
or SSBs and their
name again makes sense
single-stranded they
bind to single strand DNA
and they're binding
proteins so they're like
beads they bind to
the single strand DNA
and keep the helix
open so you can move on
now one thing is needed
next before you can
actually transcribe
the DNA is you have to
include a small primer
the issue here is that
DNA polymerases and
DNA polymerases from
the name they polymerize
and actually make DNA
as we talked about
before they do it in
the five prime to three
prime direction so DNA
polymerases don't have
the ability to attach
a new nucleotide
unless one is already
existing so they have
to have this three prime
OH group already there
so they can put a
new nucleotide and
then extend the chain
without that they cannot
do this and so to allow
for a nucleotide to
be there primase which
is a type of RNA
polymerase and RNA
polymerases can add a
nucleotide without one there
being existing we'll
add a short RNA segment
at the beginning of
the strand and then
DNA polymerase 3 which
is the main polymerase
comes down and extends
that chain You will
start adding nucleotides
in the 5' to 3'
direction, complementary
nucleotides, right?
So if there's an
adenosine triphosphate,
the oxyadenosine will add
thymidine triphosphate.
If there's a citadine
triphosphate, it
will add a guanosine
triphosphate, right?
Pair them correctly.
I mean, of course, it
makes errors, and that
happens. and you know
our polymerases have
actually a what's
called a proofreading
function which allows them
to if they put the
wrong one to go back
and remove it and then
put a new one instead
okay so when that's
done you'll have to go
back and remove the
RNA of course you can't
have RNA and DNA mixed
and that's the job
of DNA polymerase one
DNA polymerase one comes
removes that primer
which is rna in nature
and replaces it with
dna now that does
leave one single strand
sorry one bond between
the sugar and phosphate
incomplete or absent
and that has to be
tied and that's the
job of dna ligase by
the way ligation means
tying and that's where
that term come from
and so to complete the
process you need all
these enzymes to make
a mature DNA molecule
for example one also
good thing the way to
study this is to let's
say make mutations
in these particular
proteins and see what
happens like what
happens if primary is
not working what's the
outcome what happens
if ligase is not
working right and then
come up with you know
ideas and or explore
how how that affects
the DNA molecule.
Okay now again as we
discussed DNA polymerization
can only happen in
the 5 prime to 3
prime direction but as
we talked earlier the
strands of DNA are
opposite right one of them
is 5 prime to 3 prime
the other one 3 prime
to 5 prime so if we're
replicating on the
3 prime to 5 prime
strand that's going to
be easy because we're
going naturally 5 prime
to 3 prime but then
how do we replicate
the 5 prime to 3 prime
strand so again if you
look in here so this
is how you open it up
and so let's say if
this strand is the 3
prime to 5 prime you're
going to be able to go
5 prime to 3 prime fine
but what happens on
the other strand that
is 5 to 3 you can't
go 5 to 3 on a 5 to 3
and so how is that going
to work and the DNA
polymerase actually
finds a solution to
that what it does it
actually bends uh this
dna molecule the strand
it twists it 180
degrees to make it look
like it's uh three to
five so it can actually
go on at five to
three and that's kind
of another way of doing
it but the problem
with that is it cannot
twist a very long
strand it can only
twist a chunk at a time
so you twist it and
then when you get to
the end of it you let
it go grab it again
twist let it go grab
it twist and so on
and every time you let
go you're gonna have
to put a primer again
and so what happens
is uh as you're
replicating dna one strand
gets replicated
continuously it's just
moving in that 5 prime
to 3 prime direction
then that's the 3 to
5 strand but the 5
to 3 has to be twisted
uh primer put twisted
again replicated primer
put twisted again
so on and this becomes
discontinuously
replicated and so that's
referred to as the
lagging strand because
there's a little lag
and stays behind it
and the other ones
referred to as the leading
strand and so that's
where that terminology
come from leading
and lagging and also
you're gonna have a
lot of primers on the
lagging strand that all
have to be removed
by DNA polymerase one
and replaced with DNA
and then ligated with
DNA ligase okay the
person that discovered
this whole thing we
noticed when they
analyzed replication is
that they were like one
whole copy if you
stop somewhere in the
middle right and the
other one here had pieces
and those pieces
and the person that
discovered them called
okazaki was a scientist
and that's why they call
them okazaki fragments
so if you've heard
of okazaki fragments
that's what those are
it's basically before
the dna is fully
replicated you have these
pieces there okay
and so that's how it
works again we talked
about polymerase three
and its ability to
proofread and but not
all polymerases have a
proofreading function
but DNA polymerases
do but RNA polymerases
don't I'm just gonna
connect give you some
kind of a kind of
a connection here a
significant one I mean
so that's why RNA viruses
they replicate their
genome using RNA
polymerases while DNA
viruses replicate the
genome using DNA
polymerases well because
RNA viruses use
RNA polymerases RNA
polymerases do not have
a proofreading function
and because of that
RNA viruses make a lot
of mistakes and this
is the reason why
RNA viruses evolve a
lot like SARS-CoV-2
why do they change
significantly more than
something like a
smallpox virus okay so
far we've focused on
DNA replication in
prokaryotes which is the
most commonly studied
and although prokaryotic
and eukaryotic
replication are very
similar we're just gonna
focus explore here
a little bit the key
distinctions between
them and these are
distinctions sometimes
are important not from a
matter of understanding
with what each one
does but also to utilize
these differences
between prokaryotes
and eukaryotes for the
sake of selective
toxicity coming up with
different chemicals
antibiotics to let's
say kill prokaryotic
like bacteria while
sparing a eukaryotic
like our cells. So for
example the class of
antibiotics referred to
as quinolones target
a specific prokaryotic
DNA replication process
that does not exist
in eukaryotes. So
what I'm showing here,
nalodixic acid, is a
synthetic quinolone,
while ciprofloxacin, or
sometimes it's called
cipro, both are
quinolones. And what they
do is they target this
enzyme, this prokaryotic
enzyme called DNA
gyrase, which is only
found in prokaryotes.
What does gyrase do?
Well before we get to
that, a key thing to
remember is that the
chromosomes of prokaryotes
are circular while
mammalians and
eukaryotic are linear and
because prokaryotic
chromosomes are circular the
way they pack them
they don't pack them as
chromatin instead they
suprachol them basically
just take a circular
rubber band and
just keep twisting it
and twisting it that's
what a suprachol is and
if you keep doing that
that rubber band becomes
very tight and so
there's DNA modeling
enzymes in prokaryotes
called topoisomerases
that do that and you
also need enzymes to
relax those superchols
because they're so
tight and so you have to
be able to do that to
replicate and that's
the job of the enzyme
called DNA gyrase so
gyrase relaxes superchol
DNA, quinolones inhibit
that and that's how
we can achieve that
and don't forget in
eukaryotes we have chromatin
right and so chromatin
has to be remodeled
it cannot be in the
heterochromatin fashion
when it's replicated
it has to be loosened
up a little bit to
allow access and there's
one more key difference
is there's some
division of labor in
different terminology in
the polymerases of
eukaryotes versus prokaryotes
so while in prokaryotes
only dna polymerase
3 does all the replication
both in leading
and lagging in eukaryotes
you have little
division of labor you
have epsilon doing
the leading while delta
doing the lagging and
here's a figure showing
delta on the lagging
strand while epsilon
is doing the leading
strand and instead of
primase the enzyme here
is called alpha primase
and basically it it
puts what's called an
initiated DNA molecule
versus what happens in
Pocat. So essentially
the same really
just some key small
differences but you see
the process is almost the
same. You have Okazaki
fragments, you have
single-stranded binding
proteins as we talked
about before and all
the other components.
So all eukaryotic
chromosomes as
we discussed are
linear except
by the way for
fungi. Fungi are
eukaryotic but they have
a circular chromosome
fungi are interesting
group of organisms
they cannot they are
eukaryotic but they
have a lot of prokaryotic
features but anyway
the replication of a
linear chromosome has
an issue or a challenge
so to speak because
the ends of the chromosomes
have an end right
a beginning and an
end whenever you put
that primer on the
end and remove it this
actually creates a gap so
what happens especially
in somatic cells as
the cell replicates
over and over the dna
starts to shorten to
shorten and shorten
the newly formed dna is
shorter by that primer
length and over time
this becomes the quantity
of dna is so small
that it actually affects
the cell function
and they typically
eventually end up dying
by apoptosis most
somatic scales can divide
somewhere up to 50 to
80 times and after that
they die on the other
hand if you look at
our germ cells and
there's also some
lymphocytes that can do
this and some stem cells
they have an enzyme
called telomerase and
what telomerase does is
it comes and brings a
complementary RNA
segment that can go at
the end like this
and what that allows
is synthesis of this
primer in order for
you not to shorten so
for germ cells some
lymphocytes like I
said and stem cells.
They don't lose DNA
with every cycle
of replication while
somatic cells do.
And again that's why
even if you try to
culture our somatic cells
they can only propagate
in culture like 58
times before they die.
Interestingly people
discovered that cancer
cells express
telomerases and that's
why they can replicate
indefinitely and
that's why typically
when people do culture
of our cells in lab
they'll use cancer
cell lines anyway
when people discover
this initially they
thought or discovered
the telomerase they
thought this is the
the answer to
immortality but the
problem is it just
creates cancer
cells
In every recording,
you're going to
see a summary slide
basically just
kind of reiterating
what we talked
about. We've
discussed the brief
history of genetics
and significance.
We talked about the
basics of how nucleic
acids are structured,
DNA and RNA.
We talked about
chromatin and structure,
how we modify it,
histones and different
aspects of chromatin.
And we discussed
DNA replication and
compare and contrast
it in prokaryotes
versus eukaryotes.